okay save our bear 12 and welcome to
this video let's do something else I
have three games against the sky really
only three games feels like I play them
more often okay oops that doesn't look
very harmonious but probably has not too
bad quite a weird French French type of
position push up on si tu ja but
probably really yeah probably can play
any kind of nonsense against the French
no h4 really so what do i do maybe queen
bee six putting some pressure down
so I go to a 60 probably will play
Bishop t3m
okay okay let's stop this pawn a little
bit at least
okay quite sure actually why I captured
I didn't really wanted to do that was a
bit of a thing i feela here yeah because
of this yeah i mean it's playing every
move instantly which as you know I
really don't like but yeah my position
is just looking really bad so
check yeah this is like a complete
nightmare like if like a French defense
in the worst possible shape and form if
I him in Haiti idea that at least
wouldn't have played a five in this
position at least I could have cooked
Castle long but this is even even that
it's difficult here and while it's just
much better simple move like let's say
g3 is good for Bishop f4 and probably
their other more more aggressive ways to
play
hmm yeah he took her to cover them I
mean he has many many good moves problem
so I understand the longer thing yeah
castling long looks crap really crap but
I don't I don't see how to how to get my
my pieces out really don't look on g7 is
also i mean very annoying maybe like a
four and i know it's just a bad position
I really think I think Jesus reboot was
even stronger but it still can play it
for Bishop f4
yeah that's a different way of preparing
Bishop f4
maybe the movie 5 is now possible
looking at this rook I mean possible is
wrong it's it's maybe a possible threat
in that position really what about Queen
f6 isn't this a double attack
look chief I think as I think was still
possible white resigns that was that was
so big turnaround does this position is
just terrible just terrible for black I
made turn off totally totally bare 27 cm
so let's let's have a look there what
what I mean I made many mistakes this is
probably quite normal a five I don't
know about that move yeah maybe I should
go as six or something I really don't
know I'm not done I mean I never scored
well with the French when I still played
it and term I still I still like the
proper feel for this position again f6
is recommended by the engine probably
correct layer I I don't really played
this terribly Queen s7 just runs it to
this move awkward just very awkward
check and he went there directly I mean
he was like move move move sometimes
thinking a little bit helps here Bishop
f4 is just probably winning it
establishes the pawn now on d6 and I
probably have has nothing better than
this and this is just just two dead just
add it keeps this pawn and the text 27
over it's over I have no movie mean i
can't play something like that but how
ridiculous is this check hey this is
still of course bad for me but not as
bad as it could have been Queenie to
yeah I like g3 here for Bishop f4 but
okay I have this move okay this is maybe
an argument yeah
possible okay this one surprisingly the
computer is not really giving this as
that grade 4 i'd just 0.6 and see a 0.4
maybe maybe this is not that bad but
well it looks terrible with the dark
squares and everything this is a lemon
however just running into Queen f6 but
he still can go rook g4 I mean this was
not necessary yet he can do this I mean
I cannot go he five yeah this is not
working what i can do is i can take this
is a very very very very cheeky way to
play but i have to do this snow
alternative complex black here yeah b2
is really hanging something like this
Queenie five gets the Queen's traded
yeah remarkable it was a it was some
surprisingly resilient looked really bad
but wasn't that easy to kill off okay
thanks for watching